wegen ps neuer anschuldigung wird jetzt
jedenfalls die geplante verfilmung des
diesel skandals durch den produzent nico
hofmann verschoben wirklich geplant aber
es umso besser dass die verschoben
werden
sebastian pufpaff hat ihnen die
filmrechte spontan vor der nase
weggeschnappt und verfilmt den stoff
jetzt gerade hier im studio nebenan für
sat 1 ist das denn wirklich abend schön
warm bewirke natürlich ist dieses diesel
geht abend füllen das ist der wende
unter den wanderschuhen und wissen sie
wenig für die hauptrolle bekommen haben
ein
[Applaus]
aber weiter geht
das ist der deutsche vw kunde
dargestellt durch diesen billigen
rumänischen comparis.ch der erfährt dass
vw in den usa mindestens 22 milliarden
entschädigung zahlt will dann auch was
haben und was kriegt er nicht mal den
neuen duft und da ärgert dass sich der
rumäne ärgerlich macht
ab dem moment
das ist hollywood das ist geil und dann
der held des films auftritt
verkehrsminister triple brennt was macht
er ja nix das ist das ist alexander
dobrindt alexander ich hab keine anzüge
dobrindt wir machten dummes gesicht
sonst nichts wobei das ist ungerecht
immerhin hat er ja von den 800 achten
also 400 für die diese untersuchung dann
einfach mal als geheim eingestuft und in
den anderen wurde gestärkt aber ich sage
immer du wärst den skandal würden wir
jetzt anfangen zeugen töten ja das wird
also insgesamt mehr so eine billige
komödie er nee ich habe es mir so als
sozialdrama angelegt haben sie das
gehört die wollen das gehalt für den vw
vorstandsvorsitzenden auf gerade mal
zehn millionen euro täglich
der aktuelle vorstand müller kriegt auch
enno 4,9 verzichtet auf gar nichts
wir haben gestern die szene gedreht wie
der vw bus dafür von anderen managern
gehänselt wird mit solchen beträgen
das sind schicksale von den krieg die
öffentlichkeit doch nichts mit dem
winterkorn und das ist kein witz hat vw
die heizanlage zu sagen korrekt bezahlt
die von ihm jetzt die heizung abstellen
wo ist da peter alice schwarzer oder
boys ohne grenzen
ich sage nein möglichst das ist die
traurige szene seit flipper in die
schiffsschraube geschwommen aber noch
nicht verstanden was wollen sie denn mit
ihrem schönen wagen dazu honig im kopf
das ist kunst
er muss nicht sagen das steht für sich
wie im porno aber er tue wir drehen die
schlussszenen der vw kunde verliebt sich
in alexander dugin beide kaufen sich
seinen opel von tieto
das ist echte emotion powered by emotion
übrigens wir suchen noch einen investor
für unsere sitcom hör mal wer da hämmert
verstehen pr
interesse ich rufe sie an seiner person
[Applaus]